From the table here we see that for given values ​​of n,
when n is 1, f of n is 12,
when n is 2, f of n is 5,
and when n is 3, f of n is minus 2,
when n is 4, f of n is minus 9.
One way to look at this is,
that this function f defines a given sequence,
where the first member of the row is 12.
The second article in this row is 5.
The third member of the row is minus 2.
The fourth item in the row is minus 9.
As she goes on.
And you may notice that this is an arithmetic progression.
We start with 12 and then the next member ...
What did we do to get it? We took out 7.
Now, to get from the second third member ...
What are we doing? We remove 7.
Each member is smaller with 7 of the previous one.
Having this in mind, see if you can define this function from n.
Whether you can define it by a formula.
Find Function Definition.
You have to find out how equal f is from n, so
if you enter here n, give you the corresponding f of n.
Let's think a little.
We can get it starting with ...
The first member will be 12.
Then we'll get 7.
How many times will we get 7?
For the first member we draw 7 zero times.
And that's how we get only 12.
For the second member we subtract 7 once.
For the third member, we take out seven times. One, twice.
For the fourth article we subtract 7 times three times.
It seems that no matter who we are,
subtract 7 n minus 1 times,
we subtract 7 as many times as the member's number minus 1.
So this is n minus 1.
Let's check whether this is true.
So, f of 1 will be 12 minus 7,
1 minus 1, this is 0.
All this will be just 12.
f of 2 will be 12 minus 7 by 2 minus 1.
We will have 12 minus 7 by 1.
We will only pull out 7 once, which is exactly the case.
We started at 12 and took out 7 once.
f of 3, you can continue to check.
12 minus, here we have to pull out 7 twice.
We see that 3 minus 1 is 2 times.
So we'll pull out seven times.
So it seems right.
We have set the feature open.
We have determined f for this arithmetic progression.
Let's figure out another example.
In this case, we already have some definitions of the function here.
You have the row, it is shown in this table.
You can view it so that the first member is minus 100.
The next article is minus 50, the next member is 0,
the next article is 50.
It is quite clear that this is also an arithmetical progression.
We start at minus 100 and then we add 50.
Then we add another 50,
and then add 50 more.
So every member is 50 more than the previous one.
Now pause the video and think
which of these definitions for the f function are true.
There may be more than one true.
Okay, let's think.
This definition here,
one way to look at it,
is to say that I start from minus 100.
And I will add 50, n minus 1 times.
Does that make sense?
For the first article, if we start from minus 100,
we will not add 50,
we will add 50 zero times and that's right.
Because 1 minus 1 will be 0.
So this is true for n equal to 1.
Let's see, for n n equal to 2 we start from minus 100,
we need to add 50 once.
this here will be 1 because 2 minus 1 is 1!
Add 50.
No matter what number we have, no matter how many n,
we add 50 as many times as the member's number minus 1.
So here we add 50 twice.
When n is 4, we add 50 three times.
So that's true.
When n is 4, we add 50
4 minus 1, three times.
Minus 100 plus 50 at 3.
Add 50 times three times, add 50
1, 2, 3 times.
Well that gives us 50. So I choose this answer.
Now let's look at this one here.
Minus 150 plus 50n.
Okay, that's one way to say,
if n equals 1, we will have a minus ...
Actually let me draw a table for this answer.
If we have n and we have f of n.
This will be for this definition here.
If n is 1, we will have minus 150 plus 50.
Which is minus 100, yes, and that's the answer.
When n is 2, we get minus 150
plus 50 in 2, which will be ...
This is 100 and has a minus of 150,
it will be minus 50.
When n is 3, this is true of course.
When n is 3, you get minus 150
plus 50 by 3, which is equal to 0.
This is the answer.
This answer here will be correct.
But you can say, "Hey, these formulas look different."
You can algebraically rework them
and see that they are the same thing.
If you take this first,
we have minus 100 plus, let's reveal the brackets and multiply by 50,
plus 50n minus 50.
Okay, minus 100, minus 50, that's minus 150.
And then you have plus 50n.
So these two are algebraically the same definition of the function.
Now, what about this here?
Minus 100 plus 50n, will this happen?
Let's see when n equals 1,
this would be minus 100 plus 50, which is minus 50.
Well, it does not answer.
Here we have to get minus 100.
So that's not true.